[Musique]
pierre n'a pas été chanceux il vient de
subir un dégât d'eau son deuxième depuis
deux ans quelle malchance
heureusement les assurances sont là pour
ça ce dîner mais son assureur voit les
choses d'un autre oeil
après l'avoir indemnisés il lui annonce
que le contrat d'assurance résilié dans
quinze jours pierre tombe des nues sa
compagnie d'assurances peut-elle le
laisser tomber de cette façon et oui
autant l'assureur que l'assuré peuvent
résilier le contrat
en tout temps si c'est l'assureur qui se
retire il ne peut pas imposer de
pénalités devra rembourser les primes
payées en trop et ne courra pas partagé
d'informations avec les autres assureurs
sans le consentement de pierre de son
côté pierre devra vite se trouver un
nouvel assureur à qui il devra dire
qu'il a eu deux dégâts d'eau si lui pose
la question si cela complique ses
démarches
le bureau d'assurance du canada offre un
service gratuit pour l'aider le fin mot
de l'histoire
si votre assureur ne veut plus mouillé
rien n'empêche de quitter le navire
[Musique]